Benjamin I win they Moshe what are you
doing at the psychedelic conference I'm
a researcher when did you first realize
that tripping balls would be your life's
work obviously you already kind of look
like a dude that is worried ready to
things like a telex will help thank you
have you ever had actual experience of a
psychedelic healing using something yes
I have I've been suffering from shingles
went down to the jungle and I had an
ayahuasca experience I'm being
completely cured
did I do anything with them can you shut
the cameras off for anything with
erectile did you have the like barbarian
collar pre ayahuasca with a new identity
explode we are already a bit of a hippie
before TLS many of you know I'm complete
almost no sounds 45 to 50 percent of
people communicate with some non-human
entity when they hug belly where are you
doing a study like them Learning Annex
like hippy dippy university or oh it's a
high grade Harvard was these human
beings for proto humans have these
ineffable mysterious experiences that
attempt to reach and communicators a
boundary dissolution there's every
culture had are moving the cohesion of
the tribal unit effect Fortran of the
world okay that was great
could you just repeat everything that
you said yes why are psychedelics
important why shouldn't they be taboo
because they're incredibly valuable tool
to heal the human psyche they're to get
down there open it up and shake it out
have you heard of a shake weight one
where you just take it and it's a weight
I don't know if it works but
psychedelics do to the spices oh it's
like a shake weight for your brain okay
hypnagogic claim to see some people like
a Dilla journey this is drugs without
drugs yeah put your head okay Tony
history of seizures No
involving singles Oh
[Music]
[Applause]